Sydney Crosby and Elias lolm in the circle we got
a face off on Fifth Avenue we're underway here on
a Saturday night on sportset Pittsburgh here's
o Conor snapping it down low for Eller off the
end wall finds Carlson centers through everyone
back to Pon snaps it to ' Conor hands it off to
Eller on goal a snapper his shoulder to siding
tight by marstrom Eller behind and that's to O
Conor is this line goes towards centers loose at
off the crease it's bouncing around zador out up
the wall kept in by Carlson to Eric Carlson grips
it surveys back to Marin onetime block put on goal
by Crosby marom got the leg on and it's loose
it bounces towards the net but not in how did
that not go as the Flames clear two minutes for
hooking had a hooking call on Gino only way he
could stop him it was gensel what a spin move off
t look at Kel's face he couldn't believe it Malin
wins the draw Rael to Carlson just inside the
line over to Marin one timer off ired blew it
past markstrom but not into the net he did it
last night also maybe it's a sign all iron for
Gino passing to Raquel crossy speed Malin throws
it in front Crosby shoots save marks to it's loose
bouncing around Carlson into the back hand across
to Crosby listed marstrom the save arrom saying
what's all these bodies doing in my blue paint
look at the puck movement east to west Crosby's
flying into the slot and then the great play by
Carlson to pull that back off and find Crosby of
course starting on the penalty kill here we have
to get through a minute and two seconds of this
Graves penalty where they can get back to work two
of them muscle their way after each other as the
puck CLS deeper into the pen Zone not cleared
ritka's got it down low for du wish shot and
getting a piece of that selovich may have hit
iron as it goes out of play in big right here
and we'll get a look at it iron on the half wall
throws it back door and a good stick there tolex
It Wide rust is going to Sprint after the puck and
there he goes short-handed into the calary zone to
the back hand BR R back hander goes wide Eller
curls it on net that hit the outside of the cage
and they got to get back cuz now here come the
Flames three on two as hubero comes in right side
Wier missed the net LOL cross Heist for Anderson
he'll wind and blast save the Del it's big rebound
comes back to lyol in the slot throws it down
the one time blast they score Matthew Coronado
first NHL goal is a power play tally and it's
one- nothing Calgary great back down establish
some Zone entry and Zone time in their power play
setup and lolm the magician just kind of gets it
there and Coronado off on the side of the net
you see guys taking these shots from those bad
angles find a lane and have to get that goalie to
squeeze to that post a little bit of a break this
period as they try to chase down this Calgary
Flames team who's just up by one penguin trying
to finish this early season back to back off with
two points they have some work to do as the third
period gets underway Flames with the one- nothing
Advantage Crosby creates a turnover right away
knocking the puck off mapani and muscles it
down low bouncing Puck Coral by gensel up top
left tank snapshot hit a body went wide R chips
it on that it scars 18 seconds for 17 and the
Penguin have tied this game and one thanks to
Brian Russ but amazing job by Sid off the rush
to enter the zone as you can see he just stayed
with it and banked it in off markstrom who's been
unbelievable here today and maybe that's just one
and the way you're going to get it done but Sid
just a power move entering the Zone fighting
off he's a puck hounding disturbing guy can
use his speed but has the skill hands playmaking
ability to be a Difference Maker and he's a guy
I'm looking to have a big GE and bounce back
and here we go it's Smith from malan Wier he
Riley Smith wires it past marstrom and the
Penguins with two goals in the first 41
seconds of the third take a 2-1 lead didn't
go the other way look at graves he stays up
and above backland and then it's just accepting
pressure does Rael to Gino on the overload and
it's easier said to done he just had to bury
this when you look at this Play What a pass by
Gino to avoid that slide Bing penguins getting
an offensive zone draw here after the icing and
Mike Sullivan quickly sending the Crosby line
out there he wins the draw to a Tang across
gel shoots and scores first of the season for
Jake gel and the Penguin add to their lead it's
3-1 kind of he gets lost look at Jake come off
the boards and get all the way across talk about
chaos and trying to pick up guys sorted out it's
just so smoothly executed play started this season
on a three-game point streak and as Harkins plays
it off the draw but not out Anderson down low for
huberto lyol intercepts Banks it up the wall and
battling for it couldn't come up with it Cadre
does down low centers a shot there and a great
stop by n delovic in tight on lle got deflected
to the near side picked up by codre he goes up
top bombs away for hin that's wide crashes into
the end wall tied up there loose Puck as a sea
of bodies di for it it's lat Tang nearly took
it away it does come free but back to the point
Hanahan chops it blocked on its way to the net
Malin for Ricard Rael over the line didn't handle
the puck it flutters to the near Corner Hanan
pops it through the line but kept in by Smith
he'll drop it from a charging to the net shoot
scores Gino machino with an exclamation point to
this third period and it's 4-1 turnover here in a
flub clear by Hanahan and that's all they needed
to go on the attack and who was there to pick it
off Riley Smith Johnny on the spot draws players
to him drops it to have Genny Malin finds a hole
on markstrom the high slot lyol passes for Rasmus
Anderson cross I lyol skate the stick carries
behind the net hit to the ice by lat Tang bapani
for hanit he'll snap it that hit a stick bounces
around comes to huberto backhander Def Flex in and
the Flames get one back as huberto put the puck to
the goal and he's going to lead the handshake line
it's 4-2 see as it gets put in into the net here
as rust gets a piece of it another block that's
six for him here tonight and it just get thrown
to the net with Anderson crashing back door and
it hits gel skate as the him and lat Tang kind of
came together I don't know what NAD delovic could
have done to try to get a hold of that one just
an unlucky break Crosby and lyol this time on the
draw LOL wins the faceof but stepping right to it
is gensel he'll take it through Center look for
the empty net off the post you kidding me yeah
he's going to be thinking about this one did his
first of the year he had all the time and measured
it got his head up took a look it rolls back to
Rasmus Anderson he'll find huberto 30 seconds in
the game Anderson moves around gensel pass picked
off by gensel hands it off to rust racing through
Center through the empty net no mistake that time
Brian rust with the dagger and the Penguins with
a 52 lead with 22 seconds to go this so kind
of stumbles and Sid kind of recognizes that
the instincts to cover up and drop into that
lane which caused the pass to mix up and from
the other side of the ice it gets up ice gensel
we'll carry it in as the fans rise to their feet
here at PBG paints Arena the penguins are going
to pull off a perfect weekend backto back with
a two-point Party on Fifth Avenue in a 52 win
over the Calgary Flames here on Saturday night